der pussy knoten findet in der
bergrettung und beim bau von
sicherungsanlagen verwendung
es wird eine schlaufe gebildet meistens
verwendet man die mitte um diesen
kleinen knoten zweckmäßig verwenden zu
können
das seil wird mit der schlaufe umwickelt
dienten der rebschnitt beziehungsweise
des seiles werden durch die schlaufe
gezogen
es entsteht ein anker stich das seil
wird ein zweites mal umwickelt und die
seilenden durch die schlaufe gezogen
zum schluss werden die seile strenge
parallel gelegt kreuzungen müssen
vermieden werden damit er gut klemmt
wenn der musik haben
der region bzw des seiles gesteckt wird
und nur eine säule strang belastet
werden soll ist zuerst ein kreuz schlag
zu machen
danach
der raps nur zweimal und das seil
gewickelt
es wird eine kreuzung mit
hergestellt
und gehen gleich wie
mal und das seil gewickelt
das ende der regel nur
läuft gleich aus wie es anläuft
zur absicherung wird das ende durch den
kreuzweg gesteckt
und dann welt
um den einlaufenden strand gemacht
wird der pro sieg nicht am seil ende
gesteckt und beide stränge werden
belastet ist keine absicherung notwendig